federal and state laws forced the casual
and habitual pot user alike to be
careful depending on the circumstances
and where one is caught with marijuana
one could receive a slap on the wrist or
serious jail time
in Canada it is illegal to but the laws
are less stringent ly enforced here in
Vancouver British Columbia marc emery is
creating his vision of a pot lover's
utopia a place wholly devoted to a pot
smoking way of life and something he'd
like to see worldwide according to the
UN Canada has the highest number of pot
smokers in the industrialized world and
Vancouver is the center kosher salt best
thing use a few cents worth of that 3
cents worth of isopropyl alcohol and
about three cents worth of salt and it
takes the grit and resin off this bong
within 5 seconds
Emory can be found in this four-story
Emporium a wonderland that sells
everything a pothead would ever need
except the pot everything in this store
is about cannabis every single hat
thinking Wallach every book about
marijuana that's currently available
we'd like to have it and we sell a lot
of these and one of the things about
bongs is that people either like to
collect them and you can heal out of
that straw there this is kind of Mecca
this is where people come to kind of
hopefully steal our ideas upstairs for
five Canadian dollars patrons bring
their own stash to the cannabis version
of a cocktail lounge I clean my bong
especially for this occasion so that's a
plus just a very killer but in here so
here we go so is this a typical day at
the office
I wouldn't say typical I usually get to
work but I wouldn't you know the here's
the thing I thought she was very
attractive and that would lure me from
my like work routine mindset
[Music]
in my case you probably get to be more
talkative and I probably don't need that
but I would think but here's the cool
thing about how you're perceiving it in
your head is changing so I guess of a
straight person coming off here's going
on here it's Sunday and it's like better
than any other environment right and
anybody can come here and yet people
love to do that they had the hippie cat
favor then the cops Kansas City you
can't do this anymore and it just was
over right I realized that what's
happened that trip you out how much he's
talking I'm somewhere else something
London